Republican Arizona Senator John McCain
has exposed what would be the plan a to
obstruct Hillary Clinton if indeed she
is elected on november eighth you'll
remember that on october eighth of john
mccain announced that he was withdrawing
support a republican presidential
candidate Donald Trump and uh deem quote
more reasonable McCain and I agree with
that by and large the more reasonable
Republican McCain said and I'll show you
the quote Donald Trump's behavior this
week concluding with the disclosure of
his demeaning comments about women and
his boasts about sexual assaults make it
impossible to continue to offer even
conditional support for his candidacy so
John McCain took a principled stand
saying I'm not voting for Hillary I've
not voted for a Democrat maybe ever in a
very long time he said but I cannot vote
for Trump and he felt the need to say it
publicly fantastic John McCain should
absolutely be applauded for this until
two days ago being interviewed by a
Philadelphia radio talk show host while
campaigning for Pennsylvania's Pat
Toomey he revealed the plan if indeed
Hillary Clinton is elected a quote from
John McCain on 12 10 w PHT radio in
Philadelphia I promise you that we will
be united against any Supreme Court
nominee that Hillary Clinton if she were
president would put up I promise you
this is where we need the majority and
Pat Toomey is probably as articulate and
effective on the floor of the Senate as
anyone I have encountered if you thought
Republican obstructionism was bad under
President Barack Obama and it was
historically bad under President Barack
Obama just wait until potential
president Hillary Clinton takes over
it's really easy in this election to
think about Donald Trump and a Donald
Trump presidency as being a systemic and
fundamental threat in so many ways the
Supreme Court is one of those major
major ways in which we should be
horrible horrified about a trump
presidency the approach to regulating
and
doing media that could potentially be
pushed by a trump Supreme Court based on
what Trump has talked about suing media
outlets etcetera tax cuts for the rich
etcetera etcetera all of that stuff a
trump Supreme Court would be a disaster
but a Hillary Clinton presidency will
bring with it a Republican Party that is
as unwilling to work with her as it has
been willing unwilling to work with
President Obama combined with the
reality that a portion of the Republican
electorate specifically the outrageous
Trump supporters are going to get to
take a phrase from Trump at the debate
last night very nasty if Hillary Clinton
wins and uh so there's no question in my
mind that it's a fundamental paramount
importance to prevent Donald Trump from
being the next president of the United
States the best way to do that is by
voting for Hillary Clinton which I will
be doing this is not going to be an easy
thing for Hillary Clinton if you thought
win or lose as soon as the next
president is inaugurated Antonin
Scalia's Supreme Court vacancy is being
filled maybe not at least according to
what Senator John McCain is telling us
here